hi I'm LeeAnn heart and I'm Celeste  heart and together we're one heart oh my  God look at me are you me remember and I  always liked you better  or have you been for a while  [Music]  [Applause]  did you tell them you weren't me who did  you tell me of a twin who really knows  what's good for you just think that we  need some time apart for both of us oh  this is your first retreat last night  when sister you said that you didn't  have any family all I wanted was to be  together to know you better than anyone  to be recognized thank you you would  rather destroy when you fell let me be a  layout you tossed me aside like garbage  you can have me you can be me I am you  we are one  you